Ach ja – die Weihnachtsgurke.
Diese altehrwürdige und heißgeliebte
deutsche Tradition,
von der ich schon so viel gehört habe.
Aber jetzt bin ich im „KaDeWe“ in Berlin,
Deutschlands größtem Kaufhaus,
und kann keine einzige in den
Weihnachtsbäumen entdecken.
Wo sind die ganzen Gurken? Zum Glück hab'
ich selbst eine dabei.
Aber noch mal von vorn.
Ich komme aus den USA.
Und dort glauben viele Menschen,
dass sich alle Deutschen eine Gurke
in den Baum hängen.
Und viele US-Amerikaner pflegen diese
angeblich deutsche Tradition.
Die Person, die die Weihnachtsgurke zuerst
am Baum entdeckt,
bekommt ein Extra-Geschenk.
Aber ganz ehrlich: Seitdem ich in
Deutschland lebe,
habe ich hier noch keine einzige
Weihnachtsgurke gesehen.
Ich frage mal ein paar Deutsche, die ihre
Weihnachtseinkäufe erledigen.
Hängen Sie dieses Jahr eine
Weihnachtsgurke
auf [an] Ihren Weihnachtsbaum?
Ich glaube, das ist eine andere Tradition. Es
ist keine deutsche Tradition.
Bitte? Eine Weihnachtskette?
Gurke ist nicht mein Lieblingsgemüse.
Weihnachtsglocke?
Weihnachtsgurke? Nein.
Ich weiß nicht, was eine Weihnachtsgurke ist.
Und was macht man damit?
Sogar dem Weihnachtsmann muss ich die
Gurken-Tradition erklären!
Tatsächlich haben 91 Prozent der Deutschen
laut einer Umfrage noch nie davon gehört.
Wenn das also gar keine deutsche Tradition
ist, wo kommt sie dann her?
Und wie ist sie in die USA gelangt?
Ein kleiner Weihnachtszauber bringt mich in
das Bergdorf Lauscha in Thüringen.
Hier beginnt meine Spurensuche.
Wenn sich irgendwo jemand mit dem
Ursprung von Weihnachtsschmuck auskennt,
dann in Lauscha.
Seit 1597 gibt es hier Glasbläser, und seit der
Mitte des 19. Jahrhunderts
stellen sie Weihnachtsdekorationen her.
Glasbläser Michael Haberland führt seinen
Familienbetrieb in vierter Generation.
Seine handgefertigten Artikel verkauft er
weltweit – auch die Weihnachtsgurke.
Von ihrer Existenz erfährt aber auch er erst
auf einer Reise nach Kalifornien.
„Wenn du Glasbläser bist:
Machst du auch Gurken?“
Man denkt sich nichts dabei.
Wenn das der Zweite fragt, dann denkt man:
"Okay!"
Beim Dritten hab' ich gesagt:
„What the hell with the Gurke?“
Dann wurde mir eben erzählt, in Deutschland
ist es so, das ist Tradition und Sitte,
da hängt sich jeder eine Gurke dran an den
Baum.
Weiß jeder Amerikaner, dass es so ist. Nur
kein Deutscher.
Zurück zu Hause schaut er sich die alten
Glasformen seines Großvaters
aus den 1930er Jahren an.
Ich habe nach dieser Gurke direkt gesucht
und [dann] wurde ich Gott sei Dank fündig.
Und seitdem machen wir die Gurken hier.
Inzwischen verkauft er seine Gurken an
Kunden in Japan,
Norwegen, in der Schweiz und natürlich in
den USA.
Aber wenn auch er diese Tradition erst seit
kurzem kennt, wo kommt sie dann her?
Tatsächlich ranken sich einige Legenden um
den Ursprung der Weihnachtsgurke.
Eine stammt aus dem Amerikanischen
Bürgerkrieg:
Ein Gefängniswärter soll einem
verhungernden deutschstämmigen Soldaten
eine Gurke zu essen gegeben haben.
Der Mann überlebte und hing danach jedes
Jahr eine Gurke in seinen Baum.
Andere sagen, es war der US-amerikanische
Unternehmer Frank W. Woolworth,
der ab 1880 deutschen Weihnachtsschmuck
in die USA importierte.
Vielleicht sollte ich den Mann fragen, der
diese Weihnachtsstadt am besten kennt.
Ich besuche Bürgermeister Norbert Zitzmann
in der ELIAS-Farbglashütte;
die älteste, die hier noch existiert, gegründet
1853.
Herr Bürgermeister, kennen Sie die Tradition
der Weihnachtsgurke?
Kommt die aus Deutschland?
Weihnachtsgurke haben wir gedacht,
was ist denn das?
Und wir erfuhren, dass man in Übersee meint,
dass diese Gurke aus Lauscha käme
und ein ganz besonders wichtiger
Weihnachtsartikel ist.
Ich denke, irgendein geschickter
Marketing-Mann hat das erfunden.
Seit dieser Zeit werden in Lauscha tatsächlich
Gurken hergestellt,
weil viele Menschen meinen, das Typische,
was aus Lauscha kommt, ist die Gurke.
Ich bin immer noch nicht schlauer, aber es
gibt noch Hoffnung!
Ich frage Gerd Ross.
Bei seinen Recherchen für die Stadt über
Glaswaren aus Lauscha
ist er auch auf die Gurkentradition gestoßen.
Was haben Sie darüber herausgefunden?
Ich 'ein bisschen nachgeforscht
und hab' rausgekriegt,
dass es doch bei einigen Familien
der Brauch war,
ein bestimmtes Ornament im Baum zu finden,
um dann das größte oder das erste Geschenk
zu kriegen.
Und daraus wurde dann die
'Christmas-Pickle',
[die] Weihnachtsgurke gemacht.
Tja, vielleicht werden wir nie erfahren,
was es mit der Weihnachtsgurke
wirklich auf sich hat.
Auf jeden Fall ist sie eine lustige Erfindung –
und eines Tages kennen sie vielleicht auch
die Deutschen.
Ich hab' da eine Idee.